In October 2018, the Pacific Ocean brewed
one of most intense hurricanes ever recorded,
AND it hit one of the most remote places in
the world.
With so much force, it eliminated an entire
island overnight.
But this isn't the first time an island has
vanished.
It's part of a trend, so what's behind it?
The island we’re talking about is East Island,
located about 890 km northwest of Honolulu,
Hawaii.
It may not seem like much - only 11-acres,
but it’s part of one of the world’s largest
protected marine areas.
The region was home to diversity rarely found
anywhere else on earth.
It was a nesting ground for over 95% of the
Hawaiian endangered green sea turtle population
and about 200 critically endangered Monk seals
visit the area each year.
Or used to?
And considering there’s only 1,400 of these
monk seals left in the state, it’s a big
deal.
East island is now a mere 46 meter patch of
sand and scientists estimate about 95% of
the islet is underwater.
Scientists don’t know if this critical habitat
will bounce back anytime soon, and are very
concerned, since islands just don’t disappear
overnight, right?
It takes years and years of erosion.
But islands are disappearing faster and it’s
becoming more common.
Scientists have observed entire islands swallowed
whole from sea level rise in a matter of a
few short years.
From 2007 to 2014 alone, 6 low-lying islands
in Micronesia vanished without a trace.
Those were uninhabited, but as recently as
2017, people of the Carteret Islands of Papua
New Guinea are leaving their island homes
for higher ground.
As they avoid the rising sea levels, they
also face dying trees, scarcity of food, and
freshwater.
They aren't the only ones either.
The Maldives, Fiji, Marshall Islands, Republic
of Kiribati, and Torres Strait Islands are
all being affected by rising sea Island nations
across the globe are facing these same obstacles
because they’re the most vulnerable to the
results of climate change
But wait, East Island didn't disappear from
sea level rise, that was the fault of Hurricane
Walaka.
Well there’s a connection, because sea level
rise can actually make the consequences of
hurricanes worse.Higher sea levels means stronger
storm surges, which create higher floods of
water that move further inland.
Like the one that hit East Island that came
from Hurricane Wakala.
Hurricane Walaka was actually one of two major
tropical storms in the pacific; one on each
side of the ocean that reached Category 5
at the same time meaning they were forming
over 250 kilometer per hour winds.
Not only is this intense, but it’s highly
unusual behavior.
On top of that, Hurricane Walaka was much
further north than most hurricanes travel.
Scientists speculate that’s because the
Pacific’s waters are warming.
See, typically hurricanes are near the equator
because that’s where warmer waters are.
Tropical storms form when warm air rises from
warm water, causing low air pressure underneath
it.
Nearby, higher pressure air will then push
into the low air pressure, and that new air
becomes warm and rises up.
Nearby air will then come in and take the
warm air’s place as it rises.
In the upper atmosphere the warm air cools
down and creates clouds.
This becomes a swirling system of hot and
cold air being fed by the ocean’s heat and
water evaporation.
In theory more energy is released into the
storm when there is a larger temperature between
the warm water and upper atmosphere.
Although climate scientists debate and can’t
directly link storms to climate change, they
all agree that warm waters also cause stronger
storms.
And let’s face it, the pacific ocean is
getting mighty toasty.
It turns out that 2017 was a record-breaking
year for ocean waters.
But hurricanes are not just getting severe
in some far off distance place in the Pacific,
we can see the intensity from the Atlantic
as well.
The recent North Carolina hurricane dropped
over 75 cm of water on parts of North Carolina
and many areas were flooded and blocked off.
As for East Island, we’ll see how it fairs.
NOAA will monitor the islands progress to
see how the animals respond to their habitat
loss, and what they find will help them manage
the species.
Some monk seals can already be seen lifting
themselves up on the small patch left behind.
So yes, sea levels are rising, hurricanes
are getting worse, and they’re wiping places
off the map.
While we can’t witness what’s going on
beyond our backyards..it’s all happening
right now, even if we can’t see it.
Islands may be disappearing, but you know
what won’t vanish?
Your very own website with Domain.com!
Domain dot com is awesome, affordable, reliable,
and has all the tools you need to build a
new website.
They can fulfill all your website needs.
They offer dot com and dot net domain names,
and intuitive website builders.
They have over three hundred domain extensions
to fit your needs, from dot club to dot space,
dot pizza!
Take that first step in creating an identity
online and visit domain dot com.
Want updates on the status of your earth,
subscribe!
And check out this video to hear what happens
if global temperatures get too warm by just
2 degrees celsius.
It’s a doozy.
Also the strongest hurricane ever recorded
in history was Hurricane Patricia back in
2015 which reached up to 346 kilometer per
hour winds.
Thanks for watching and I’ll see you next
time on Seeker